we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P here's a caller who at
least seems to think that he caught me
in a double standard let's listen this
is interesting
something else that I truly don't
understand all right
you are in favor of allowing women
to decide what to do with their body
true abortion
have a child
Etc right guilty perfect
sounds reasonable to me all right good
yet on the other hand
you criticize
perhaps make fun of people who want to
dictate how they want to treat their
particular illness or infectious disease
you can't have it both ways man explain
you can
I'm gonna exaggerate and say something
stupid but on purpose if I want to treat
covet or some other illness or
infectious disease with bleach
with cockroach killer with uh
sawdust okay
you should let me do it
don't criticize it
there's two different things here
you should let me do it versus you
shouldn't criticize it and I'm sorry my
friend there is no double standard here
okay I have never advocated that it
should be illegal for an individual
who's confused right to go to the
hardware store
to buy Bleach or Drano
or whatever
and to apply it to the body
interior extra whatever
because they think that it'll treat
covet I have never said it should be
illegal I have never said when you go
and you grab bleach
they should ask you are you going to use
this for covet and if you say yes they
call the cops I have never said it
should be illegal what I have said is
it's stupid what I have said is there's
no medical science that says injecting
bleach is good for covet there is no
double standard I don't think abortion
should be against the law it should be
up to individuals to decide for
themselves whether that's something they
want to do abortion is an
extraordinarily safe medical procedure
in most cases it's not even a procedure
it's a it's a medication
we know all about it and it should
nobody should be forced to have an
abortion but it should be available
people should decide similarly I am fine
with people deciding oh I'm gonna uh uh
I have coven and I really don't feel
well I'm having trouble breathing I'm
gonna check myself into the hospital or
I'm gonna go and get bleach
both should be legal options the
evidence is that the bleach not only
doesn't work but it could really hurt
you and so again in going with the
Medical Science
doctors shouldn't prescribe bleach
okay there's no double standard here uh
but interesting interesting perspective
we've got a great bonus show for you
today First Republic Bank has failed and
it has been taken over by JPMorgan Chase
what is this doing to the economy we
will discuss we're going to talk about
weight bias in the workforce bias
against heavy people overweight people
obese people and it is actually worse
for women than men based on the data we
have very interesting story we're also
going to delve a little bit deeper into
the search for a replacement for Tucker
Carlson all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show get instant access to
the bonus show by signing up at
joinpakman.com that is a freaking
Predator right there the bonus show is
not predatory it's open and available
for you if you want it simply sign up at
joinpakman.com otherwise I'll be back
here tomorrow